welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss this video is brought to you by
Pluto TV the free streaming platform
offering free movies and shows that are
100 free 100 of the time and this is a
breakdown of the trailer the season
finale of House of the Dragon an episode
that we know will be called The Black
Queen what climactic confrontations for
the book will this series defy the
continuity of the book to LEAP to what
new fetishes will Lair strong dare us to
King Shame let's go through this trailer
frame by frame to find out the trailer
opens with rain East on dragon pack
flying across the sea to Dragonstone on
her Dragon melees right after escaping
the dragon pit in episode 9. Melius is
described in the text as having Scarlet
wings and Peak scales she looks
desaturated in Gray here but in some
frames when the light catches the wings
just right they do look more pink rainy
is going straight to rhaenyra to warn
her was Alison NATO's biggest fear and
by locking up rainey's last episode and
insisting the coronation be held in the
dragon pit to symbolically adore an egg
on the second with as much Targaryen
history as possible directly led to
rainey's humiliating them like this
rainy says screens are coming for you
rhaenyra
and for your children
race is still in her Dragon Rider armor
she wasted no time to get to them Damon
holds his sword Dark sister and rhaenyra
holds her stomach containing their third
kid who will be named vizenia vizinia is
named after aegon the Conqueror sister
wife and zenya the original wielder of
dark sister so in a way demon and
Rainier are both wielding the same
ancestors memory both Damon and Rainier
are wearing black already wearing the
colors of their faction as a member of
the blacks but contextually they might
just be wearing this color to mourn King
viserys and they're adopting this color
to Mark themselves as The Heirs best
trying to honor viserys's Legacy various
other shots of Dragonstone whereas
episode 9 focused on the greens faction
the finale will focus on the blacks
faction inside the Great Hall of
Dragonstone you can see the fires
burning beneath the painted table later
in the trailer we see their purpose to
illuminate from beneath the dragon glass
so that the map of Westeros was revealed
this was the the true original design of
the painted table based on George or
Martin's text whereas the version we see
in the Game of Thrones series had more
of an engraved and painted design but
like aegon the conqueror's dagger the
true imprint was hidden beneath the
surface by pyromancers and revealed by
fire we get a great look at this painted
table overhead and this shot reveals
just the northern half of the Westeros
continent we see King's Landing at the
far right of the frame and then Slightly
North of that the God's eye Lake and
Harren Hall and the riverlands as well
as the veil of Aaron and the Eerie and
then the Twins and then to the far north
white Harbor and Winterfell and then to
the left of that even further north not
illuminated is the wall a shot shows
aemond removing his eye patch now
beneath that eye patch in his eye socket
will be a bright blue sapphire the
opening credits imagery of episode 9
already hinted at this with eamon's
bloodline dial his sigil being a
sapphire a lord pushes Ranier to lay
Siege to the red keep he's joined by
maester gerardus and a few Knights of
the King's Guard who must have defected
Sir Eric will be among them and at the
end there is Sir Stefan darklin he is
the kingsguard who announced Vernier in
Damon's arrival in episode 8 where most
of the other kings guard completely
stiff them from another end of the
painted table we see Jace and Luke and
Bayla and Rayna offering their services
Jason Luke wearing crimson and black of
course their house colors Bayla and
Reyna also wearing these colors a
close-up show is a gloved hand gripping
sword I assume this is either Jace or
Luke but then in the rain we see Luke
running toward his Dragon RX I love
these two wasting no time to run up and
greet each other a shot a few moments
later actually shows Luke flying on this
relatively smaller Dragon through a
storm another shot shows lightning
Illuminating vagar outside the walls of
Storm's end showing just how massive the
dragon is even larger than the castle
itself now I've been pointing out at my
breakdowns throughout the season all the
references to Storm's end in the recent
desire for the greens to appeal to Boris
Baratheon at Storm's end a lord who
would be more sympathetic to whatever
side rhaenys would be on since his
father Borman Baratheon asked for her
favor during the tourney in episode 1
and is long considered rhaenys the
rightful ruler of Westeros I don't
really want to say too much about what's
gonna happen here it is just gonna be a
huge moment and despite what you may
have heard or read in the book I do
suspect that this sequence will go down
different the writers of this series
throwing a curveball at people who know
the book history forget about the
curveball Ricky give him a heater Pluto
TV has on-demand and linear channels
curated by real people who select the
movies and channels you love some of
your favorite binge-worthy shows and
movies have their own channels that you
can watch 24 7 comedy drama sci-fi
horror and for house the dragon fans
plenty of fantasy they've got it all and
it's all free head to pluto.tv to check
it all out Sir Eric presents viserys's
Crown to renera in the book it's sir
Stefan darkland who steals the crown but
it looks like they're gonna give the
honor to a different kingsguard then
there is a huge dragon eye with Damon
reflected in it this is part of an
interesting moment
[Music]
this dragon is vermithor the dragon of
King jaharis that was viserys's
grandfather the predecessor whom we
started the season with at the great
Council of 101 River Thor is the third
biggest dragon on record right after
Valerian the black dread who's now
deceased and the current largest dragon
vegar that is eamon's Dragon so Damon
trying to sing Valyrian to verb
Authority deer himself is a pretty
daring move and a surprising one Burma
Thor made his lair in the caverns of the
dragonmont that's where we saw Damon
spelunking at the beginning of episode 8
and where he found three new eggs laid
by Cyrax now in the text Verma Thor is
approached out of a need by the blacks
to increase their dragon rider numbers
but he actually gets mounted by a
blacksmith's bastard named Hugh Hammer
yes it does sound like the name of a
male porn star but just be grateful we
don't get another character named Eamon
agar agenda aegon Damon vavan David
David
it's all the same now I would hope that
we get you hammer on a series not sure
though if it is now Damon that's
approaching this Dragon also not sure
what it tells us that Damon would be
singing to Burma Thor when he already
has a dragon craxies or does he still
have that Dragon here a little later a
wide shot shows Burma Thor breathing
fire all over the cavern as demon stands
before him completely on phase and a
wide shot of Dragonstone we see three
dragons departing Cyrax and craxies but
then another one in the background that
is either ver Max or RX maybe mellie's
probably not Bayless Dragon Moon Dancer
because at this point it's no larger
than a horse this could be part of
Rainier's campaign to return to King's
landing on Dragon back as she promised
Allison she would at the end of episode
8. on the Dragonstone bridge where Otto
and Rainier confronted Damon and
Missouri in episode two the characters
meet again but on different sides
slightly rhaenyra is now siding with
demon reading a letter brought to her by
Otto and you can see renera is crowned
with viserys's crown at this point so I
assume that crowning will happen early
on in the finale Damon unsheets dark
sister as three kingsguard flank him
maybe they're gonna pick off three of
the seven King's Guard meanwhile behind
Otto is Meester Orwell and it looks like
one other kingsguard which would mean
the three remaining Kings guard
including sir Kristen Cole stay behind
with aegon II and Allison and King's
Landing we end on a shot of bagar in the
rainstorm his mouth snapping shut over
two massive fire breathing holes I'm so
excited for this sequence because using
rain and lightning is a long proven
cinematic go-to to help make nighttime
battles and nighttime monster sequences
look more Vivid because yeah obviously
these series have run into a bit of
trouble shooting scenes at night time
like in episode 6 of House of the dragon
and in the Game of Thrones season 8
episode the long night but both of those
were devoid of precipitation would have
really benefited from having it rain
during them because just having it rain
during these kind of scenes just goes
such a long way like think and Peter
Jackson's The Two Towers the Helms Deep
battle it looked amazing because of the
rain it allowed all the surfaces to
reflect light better and just make all
the swords and helmets and axes and
arrows and Orcs And elves and everything
looked more visible same for Steven
Spielberg's shots and Jurassic Park's
most famous scene all that rain helped
cover the visual imperfections on the
T-Rex and make it look far more lifelike
as its rain-soaked reptilian skin
reflected the lightning often when you
watch movies and TV shows where
characters are walking down streets are
on pavement those streets are often wet
posed down by the production crew just
before they start rolling just when
surfaces are wet like that it just shows
up better on film and it looks like it's
gonna be the same thing for vegar here
with the rain and the lightning we're
gonna be able to see everything and it's
gonna look incredible but again the
question left from the book readers is
will the battles that we know are coming
in this finale go the same way when it
comes to the fates of these characters
like why is Damon greeting burmathor
this series is already diverged from the
book with rhaenice's escape from the
dragon pit sir Harold still being alive
at this point the fact that aegon's
dream is in the dagger and is motivated
these characters the fact that Helena
seems to be a dreamer and the fact that
Leonor is still alive making his Dragon
sea smoke still a wild card who could
affect everything so yeah there are many
ways all of this could go and thanks
again to Pluto TV for sponsoring this
video Pluto tv offers live channels and
on-demand blockbuster movies stream now
pay never let me know what you're most
excited to see in this finale episode
you can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at avos follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]